See, I'm happy.
If you weren't here, I'd be sad.
My my little heart would have broken.
[Silence]
What young guys come up sit right here.
Front and center.
Come on, tough guys.
Right in the middle there.
There we go.
[Silence]
There is
a narration
of our prophet
Alayhi Wasallam
that in this narration, it tells us
how many gates
there are
to paradise.
Who can tell me that number?
How many?
Eight.
Very good. Correct.
How many gates
to the hellfire?
Mhm.
Seven.
Perfect.
Seven gates to the hellfire.
Eight gates to paradise.
Do you know what that means?
What do you understand from that?
Allah is expecting more people to go to
Jannah than hell.
Jannah than hell. Very good.
And also, what does that mean for you
and me?
What does that tell us about our
chances?
So, we
have a stronger chance
of going to paradise
than we do
of going to the hellfire.
Isn't that amazing?
When a person does one good deed,
just one,
at least
how many is it counted as?
Mhm.
10.
Is it only 10 or could it be more than
10?
It could be hundreds, right? Could be
thousands.
As a matter of fact, there are some
people that have entered paradise
because of a single good deed that they
did.
But what about when a person commits a
sin? Someone
disobeys Allah.
They lose their battle with a Shaitan
with that particular thing. How many
sins is written?
For paradise, it's it's one.
for paradise, it's 10, at least. Always.
Every good deed is always written at
least
10 times.
When a person does a sin, how many is it
written as? Tell me.
One. Is it ever written as more than
one?
Yeah? So, a person could commit one sin
and it would not be written as just one,
it would be written as more than one.
No.
This is why we're doing this, so we
learn.
You can never commit a sin
and have it written more than just one,
ever.
You can never do a good deed
and have it written any less than 10,
right?
But you can never commit a sin and have
it written any more than
one.
So,
what does this tell us about our chances
of going to Jannah?
High or low?
Higher and higher, right?
Eight gates to paradise,
only seven gates to the hellfire.
I do one good deed, at least 10 times.
I do one bad deed,
never more than one.
And it could just
be erased just because
just because Allah is forgiving. Just
because Allah decided to.
Just because Allah
is a Rahman Raheem.
Now,
we want all of the youngsters off the
walls. We want them in the front. Come.
Come.
Come sit up here in the middle.
This is for you guys.
Now,
how big is the gate to paradise? Who can
tell me this?
There's a narration
that tells us how wide the gate to
paradise is.
It's not just eight eight
doors.
Each door
is how big?
Anyone know?
Anyone even
years of travel.
years
of traveling. You know what that means?
That means if you jumped in your car
today
and drove as fast as you can for 40
years,
that's how long it takes to get from one
side to the other
of the door of Jannah.
That's how
big
the door to Jannah is.
Amazing, right?
How you going to fill up such a place?
If that's just the door,
how big is the actual Jannah itself?
So, if we took all of humanity right now
on the earth, all of us,
how many human beings are on earth right
now?
Approximately.
Well, aren't you the little scientist?
Our little
statistician.
Good.
Around eight
billion people.
Now, the earth is a big place.
If I were to jump in my car and drive
straight over the equator,
keep driving,
would it take me 40 years to go across
the whole earth?
40 years? How long would it take?
Maybe a
couple months, something that?
So, imagine how many times I'd have to
travel
to go for 40 years.
Now, there's 8 billion people on earth.
That sounds a lot, and it is a lot
of people.
But if we were to take all those people
and put them in one place,
they would fit in a pretty small area.
They couldn't live that, obviously,
cuz you need room to sleep and sit down
and walk around and so forth. But if we
were to just collect them all,
they could all fit in
California alone.
So, why do we need such a big gate? And
why do we need such a big place? How
could that ever get filled up?
If we took all the Muslimin
from the time of Adam until the last
human being,
all of them,
we would have billions of people, right?
Would that fill paradise up? Even if we
took all of them, would it fill paradise
up?
Nah.
It wouldn't just not fill it up. There
is a lot of leftover space.
So, here's the question.
If Jannah is really that big
and humanity,
all of us going in there, even with the
jinn, we can't still fill it up,
how is Allah going to fill up the rest
of the places that are open in Jannah?
Who can tell me this? I will be
blown away. Who's going to blow my socks
off? I I have any socks on. So, who's
going to blow my hat my hair back? Yes,
Asim, tell me.
What was the question? Tell me.
How is Allah going to fill up all of
paradise, all that extra space? How's he
going to do it? Tell me.
So, the
So, the all the other people are going
to spread
the spread
them out. Mhm. And they try to look
after their family on Earth.
Mhm.
There's going to be a lot of leftover
space, man.
We got to fill it up. We got all this
space. How's Allah going to fill it up?
Yes.
Whatever you want.
Even if he gives you whatever you want.
Because
there are thousands and thousands of
levels of paradise.
And each two levels
is how far apart? Anyone know?
How far is
one level
to the next level of paradise?
Tell me, somebody, anybody.
We don't even know.
As far
as you can look and see the furthest
star
in the sky.
That's how far between one level of
paradise and the next.
That's how big Jannah is.
That's how huge and enormous Jannah is.
Are 8 billion people going to fill that
up?
Are 80 billion people going to fill that
No, it's way too big. Yes, young man.
You will see Allah, inshallah, all of
us.
So, back to our question, how's he going
to fill it up?
I'll tell you how he's going to fill it
up. Does anybody else know? Somebody
tell me. Anyone.
For our good.
Allah will fill up all of paradise.
And then there's all this extra space
left.
He's going to create new people
that have never done anything wrong,
have never done anything right.
Just to fill up the rest of paradise.
That's amazing, isn't it?
Now, what about the hellfire? How is he
going to fill that up?
This is an important question. Yes, sir.
Mhm.
No, he's not going to create new people
to fill it up.
There's a way to make the hellfire it's
too big. It's already filled up. He's
going to now
find a different way to make it. Now,
remember the pattern here.
One good deed, 10.
One sin, just one.
Eight doors to paradise, only seven to
the hellfire.
There's leftover room in paradise, he
creates people just to put them into
paradise.
Does Allah want to punish people?
Now, this this tells us something about
Allah, right? So, how is he going to
fill up the hellfire?
Tell me. He's probably not going to fill
it up because he doesn't want to punish
No, he's going to fill it up.
He's going to fill it up. You know why?
Because there are people who insist on
going to the hellfire.
Doesn't matter if they receive
messengers, doesn't matter how many
chances they're given, whenever they
feel comfortable or get the upper hand,
they will
oppress
and transgress
and
cross boundaries, they insist
on going to hell.
So,
they will go.
And the hellfire is going to be filled
up. But how is it going to fill up?
Anyone else know?
Yes.
Huh?
No.
Asim, you know?
You don't know, you just raising
your hand. Okay.
What did you say?
He's going to make it smaller.
What do you think of that?
If I have it filled up and there's still
room,
I can do one of two things. I can either
add more people or I can make the place
what?
Smaller.
So, he's going to
shrink the hellfire, he's going to smash
it together
until there's no more room left over.
Do you guys notice here what we're
talking about?
This is telling us about our chances cuz
every one of us
has to go to either Jannah or the
hellfire. We have to. You can't go
there's no middle place, there's no I
don't want to play this game, there's no
I just don't want to exist. No, you have
to go to one. You have to.
You're a human being,
you're not an animal. Allah chose you,
put your soul into a human body,
you have to go to one of those two
places, either paradise or the hellfire.
So,
we got to look at our chances. What are
the chances I'm going to go to Jannah?
What are the chances I'm going to go to
Jahannam? This is a question we have to
ask ourselves.
So,
what does that tell us about our
chances?
What
is
the chance that we are most likely going
to go to Jannah?
High or low? What's the What's the
likelihood? More likely to go to Jannah
or more likely to go to a Nar?
Yes.
To Jannah. Jannah, right?
As a matter of fact,
it is so likely to go to Jannah
that you have to go out of your way
and try
to go to Jahannam.
You have to put in effort,
consciously put in an effort
to go to Jahannam.
So, Jannah is right there.
Everybody, every one of us can go there.
And so,
what does Ramadan do for our chances of
going to Jannah?
Tell me, Asim.
Fasting. What does it do?
Your chances go from regular, already
good chance,
to extremely high.
That's why.
Listen to this narration. Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
he tells us
that
the real loser
You want to know who is a loser?
A real loser
is someone
who lives through Ramadan and still
doesn't get forgiven.
That person is a total loser.
You know why?
Is a total loser?
Because how could you mess something
that up?
You just have to try just a little bit
and you will be forgiven.
Yet in spite of that, you still went out
of your way
to avoid being forgiven by Allah.
So, Ramadan is in a few days.
All we have to do
is try a little bit.
By a show of hands
here in this room,
how many people
have fasted 20 Ramadans?
20.
Akeem, right?
Okay, how about 10?
10 Ramadans.
How many have fasted 10 Ramadans?
No.
10.
What about five?
Five Ramadans.
How many of us have fasted one Ramadan?
Obviously, the whole masjid. Now, I want
to ask you a question.
Can you think back to yourself before
that first Ramadan,
that first day?
Did you notice that you were a different
person at the end of that month than you
were from the first one? Or were you the
same person largely?
How many of us still have habits from
last Ramadan that we haven't given up
yet? We still have them. I started them
last Ramadan and I did not believe it.
Now, imagine if we did that with just
one thing every Ramadan.
Just one thing. Not a hundred things. I
don't want to wear 10 hats. I don't want
to become the saint of Tucson in Ramadan
this year. No, no, no. I'm not trying to
do that.
I just want to change one thing about
myself
in worship. I'm not talking about I want
to lose weight. I want to, you know,
sleep better. I'm not talking about
that. I'm speaking about your
relationship with Allah, the thing that
matters, the only thing that matters.
Really?
One thing
that you either leave off and will never
go back to it again
for this Ramadan.
Or one thing that you are failing to do.
Questions are over. One thing that you
are failing to do
that you will never stop doing again
once
this Ramadan is completed. Just one. And
you know what? I know that every one of
us knows exactly what that one thing is.
We all have a list of things we
shouldn't be doing, right? Every one of
us. We all have a list of things that we
should be doing.
And you know, often times the idea is
like, "Oh,
we need more knowledge." It's not an
issue of knowledge. It really isn't.
Because if I told you
today
tonight, in 5 hours, you are going to
die. It's going to happen tonight in 5
hours. You have 5 hours.
You make the best out of it. I'm sure
every one of us would know exactly what
he would do with those 5 hours.
Correct?
Would any of us be confused as to
what to do in those 5 hours? Absolutely
not.
24 hours.
Of course, if if you learn from movies
what to do before your death,
the movie is going to tell you
you got to go find your family
and spend time with them.
Tell them you love them.
Right?
Your family's not going anywhere.
When you die and they die, you're going
to meet on the other side. This is just
a bump in the road.
That is the psychology of people who do
not believe there is a hereafter.
And spending time with my family, that's
great. I'm not saying that that's wrong,
but that's not something I can put in my
pocket and take with me to the next
life, now is it?
No.
So,
there is
a story. I'm going to tell you this
story. We're going to stop there.
Al-Hasan al-Basri,
one of the great fuqaha
of al-Basra,
he went to a janazah funeral.
And
a man was being buried.
And he had his students around him, of
course, as you would at a burial, right?
People come. Everyone is watching the
body be lowered.
And he asked a very
a very interesting question.
He said,
"If you all were in this man's place
right now,
you were being lowered into your grave
right now. And you had a chance to come
back
miraculously, a second chance.
Air
fills your lungs for another time. You
rise from the dead and you've got
another chance at life. What would you
do with that chance?"
And so, they all said exactly what we
all would say.
"Oh, I would
I would just I would pray more. I would
be more truthful. I would be more this.
I would not lose these
etc." All the things that we know we
should be doing
or those things which we shouldn't be.
And so then, after everyone thoroughly
imagined this situation,
he said,
"Well, here's your second chance."
Look at that.
You have that chance right now. He's
dead. He's gone. But we still have that
chance.
We can still make that decision.
What we do not want to see
this Ramadan
is we do not want to see the same old
story.
I want to start out at the beginning of
Ramadan hot and sweaty and I'm going to
do everything and then the second day,
third day, the body gets used adjusts to
the fasting. Everything gets back into
routine and then slowly
it's just another day of the year again.
And then a shaytan comes and says, "Man,
you messed it up. ,
you
you messed up this time. It's not
perfect. The whole 30 days, you messed
up.
Next Ramadan, inshallah." Okay, this
Ramadan is it's done. It's it's blessed.
For- forget it. It's it's it's over. You
already messed it up. Next Ramadan,
[Arabic recitation]
You know, we're smiling because every
one of us has exactly that exact same
whisper. How do I know about it?
Cuz I hear that same voice with that
same reasoning.
However,
if we reset every time we go to Ramadan,
how are we going to get better? It's
never going to happen. And that's why we
see people who fast 20, 30, 40, 50, 60
Ramadans
and they are still the exact same person
that they were. As a matter of fact,
they might even be a little worse. Their
heart might be a little bit
harder.
They might be more stuck in their ways
now. They might be more stubborn and
impatient.
You cannot give up on your soul. It's
your soul. You can't give up on it.
You have to continue to fight, to walk
down that path. You choose one thing.
One. Don't change anything. Just one
thing.
And that can be as simple as, "I will
never speak a lie again."
Start with that one.
"I will never utter falsehood again for
the rest of my life,
whether intentionally or
unintentionally.
I will never speak bad about my Muslim
brother again, ever. And I will never
tolerate it again." That's your only
thing.
And then you're going to fight with
yourself through the whole month
to stay on that bucking horse
until it obeys.
One thing.
If we do this,
we will never be the same people again.
We will And there we have lots of
activities for the youngsters.
Inshallah, I want to see every single
one of you in the masjid in Ramadan,
right?
You going to be fasting? Is everyone
here fasting?
Are you fasting, Hassan? You're not
fasting. Are you fasting?
Okay. Well, I'll be watching you. I'm
going to check you when you guys come
in. Make sure you're fasting.
All right, guys. Let's go
get some
Let's go get some candy from my office.
What do you think?
Mhm.
Let's go.